yeah great okay plastic pairs
says hell yeah right up my alley thanks
for getting bernardo on the show
if consciousness is beyond localization
does that imply that the brain is like a
radio tuner
look i think the radio metaphor is
useful if you're coming from a dualist
background or a pure materialist
background it helps you
think about the issues we are talking
about
i don't think it is ultimately true
though because it's a duelist metaphor
there is the signal and there is the
tuner or and they are separate things
like if if the brain is a filter then
the brain itself cannot be made of
consciousness
otherwise you know can you talk about a
coffee filter made of coffee
you can't it would filter nothing a
coffee filter made of coffee wouldn't
work
so if i say that everything is
consciousness and even the brain
is merely the image of certain conscious
processes it's the image of the thing
and as such
it cannot filter consciousness because
it is itself consciousness
now i think what's happening is that the
brain is the image of a dissociative
process in consciousness
and dissociation happens in a way
that can things happen because of
dissociation
as if the brain were a filter
if you see what i mean because the brain
is the image of a dissociate
dissociative process things happen as if
it were a filter
because dissociation is exclusive it
excludes certain things it creates a
boundary and it differentiates what's in
from what's out
and that's like a kind of filtering in
which you let certain things in and you
keep other things
out so things work as if
the brain were a filter and that's the
sense in which i think
metaphor is useful but the brain is not
literally a filter
because you cannot have a coffee filter
made of coffee and for the same reason
you can
cannot have a filter of consciousness be
made of consciousness
i think it's just an image of a
dissociative process that works as if it
were a filter
and when you say it's an image of a
dissociative process
as seen from the second person on a
first person pers like the first there's
a first person perspective associated
with it one of the
what tripped me up initially and maybe
this will help some other people is that
when we think of mind
we tend to think of our example of mind
within our mind within our head i know
that's you don't like the within our
head aspect
but the way that thoughts relate to
other thoughts
it's volutinous and indistinct and
equivocal
so how could something as precise and
serene as
paper and the natural laws of physics
come from mind
well i guess i'm posing that as a
question but that's my way of saying it
out loud to clarify for some of the
audience members who are wondering how
could this all be in mind
given that our own example of mind is
nowhere near as precise as the
external world seems to be
our individual mind has arisen
from evolutionary processes through
cooperation and competition and
competition uh in a
in an ecosystem and because of that
our mind is largely reactive it works in
a
impulsive reactive unstable way
because it has helped us survive if if a
tiger
would be stalking you it would help you
survive to react very quickly
to any sign that the tiger might be
stalking you
you'd have to react to things to survive
some forms of impulsive behavior are
also
conducive to survival they allow for
quicker reaction time
um reproduction you know it's nice to be
hopelessly in love with someone that
will guarantee reproduction
so you cannot compare
the dispositions of our human mind
which have been shaped by competitive
and collaborative pressures
through evolution you cannot it cannot
compare the
more or less valuable and
and and reactive character of our
orientation
to the mentation of a mind that has
never undergone this competitive
pressures
that other mind does not need to react
to an environment
does not need to react to threats does
not need to fall in love
because it's what there is there is
nothing outside it it's what there was
there is and there
always will be so that mind has
no reason to become reactive and and
and and uh trigger happy
like our minds is or valuable like our
like our minds are
because it didn't have to survive an
ecosystem and compete and react
to to external influences so how would
it be
instead it would be exactly what it
seems to be
quite stable unfolding very predictably
according to its own mental archetypes
and we know it's stable because we can
model the behavior of nature
it doesn't change its laws from one day
to the other it seems to behave quite
stably
and what is a stable mind it's an
instinctive mind i offer you an example
even lower animals not too low even
crocodiles
have very instinctive minds that are to
some extent reactive they will react
fast to threats but that fast reaction
is predictable
crocodiles are incredibly predictable
predictable you can you can
measure what distance between them and
you
they have to be at in order to try to
lounge at you
if the distance is higher than that they
will not even try if it's shorter than
that
they are guaranteed to try to lounge at
you and eat you
so instinctive minds are very
predictable
minds in the case of the universe i
think it's distinctive but in addition
to that
it's not reactive either because it's
all there is it doesn't have anything to
have to react
to and that seems to be exactly how it
behaves
what occurs to me right now with this
instinctual metaphor is that
it seems like there's a bit of assuming
what you're trying to prove there
so for example let's take a fly and then
you shine some photons on the right side
and then it's wings on the left
move okay the way we explain that is
mechanistically
and without mind traditionally
so then this would be an example of
either demonstrating that the universe
is mechanistic at its core or that
you're saying well
well mind is what is mechanistic but i'm
asking you about the mechanistic aspect
of mind yeah
i i i know exactly where you're coming
from you're saying aren't you
just projecting onto reality what you
expect to see
in reality and no
it's making a theory unfalsifiable when
you manage to construe every piece of
evidence
in the light of your theory then you
turn it into something
unfalsifiable um some people i mean i am
a believer in evolution by natural
selection i don't think it's random
but i think evolution by natural
selection happens and some people who
are in favor of evolution by natural
selection make it unfalsifiable because
you see
if the bird of paradise has these super
colorful
feathers that make it obvious in an
environment it's because
it attracts mates that way by making
itself very conspicuous
it will attract mates mates will see him
and he will be more attractive that's
why it has
feathers but if it's a black bird that
you can hardly see it's boring to death
then oh it survives because
it's camouflaged and the predators can
see so you can you can make the theory
unfalsifiable if you go down this path
luckily that's not what we are doing
today to to defend uh
the theory of evolution there are
genetic studies there are experimental
studies
so it runs a little deeper than that but
i am sensitive to this idea of turning
a theory into something unfalsifiable by
interpreting everything favorably
i don't think that is what i'm doing and
i tell you why
if i start from the premises of the
theory everything is mental and we are
part of mind but nature at large is also
mental in nature
what would you expect to be the case
based on what we know about life the
universe and everything
i would be surprised if nature were
valuable unpredictable and reactive
under the framework of my theory
because it wouldn't fit with my theory
because you see
our minds have undergone very different
shaping forces and dynamics than the
mind that has never needed
to undergo evolution so i the theory
suggests or implies that these two types
of mind a dissociated one and a natural
one
should behave very differently because
one has undergone the pressures of
natural selection and the other
didn't so i think what we are observing
is a direct
i i think that the universe is
predictable and behaves itself
differently than our own minds
is what you would expect if the theory i
am proposing is correct
anything else would sort of contradict
it because then you would say well
how can these minds be the same one has
undergone the pressures of natural
selection and the other hasn't
so by what miracle are they the same it
would be dissonant
it wouldn't be nice so i don't yeah